foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
he wasn't in the next door video yeah
get off my Lawns as the person from the
next video over like I'm imagining well
hey everybody it's [__] Friday
finally getting ready to go to Club this
is like the longest week ever I suppose
yeah you know what I mean it seemed like
but uh yeah we're getting ready to go to
Memento Mori this evening after the show
so that's why we're all decked out well
I'm decked out yeah you guys should see
what she's got what I'm seeing right now
she's wearing this dress
it's slit all the way up the side it
goes slid all the way up almost to her
armpit right now she's got a corset on
over it she you could wear it either way
it looked good it looked good either way
but without that corset it's still
[__] sexy it looks like she's got a
loincloth on
and a bunch of like show them put your
leg up in there and show them the fish
nets or the uh uh she's got snake fish
nets yeah well I forgot I had these this
is what happens sure I forgot well I
don't know if I can do that it's kind of
like yeah I don't know if you can really
see him but yeah it's like a snake
I forgot what happened when but remember
back on Halloween when I did my Medusa
costume and I actually bought a bulk
pack of snake fishnet tights I think it
was a six pack
um because I used one of them for
sleeves and I used one of them for
tights and I forgot that I still had
like three or four pairs of them that
were yeah that were virgin that I had
not worn before so I was like oh look at
these so I was like
go me I'm gonna wear that I haven't worn
this dress out yet
so we'll see how it goes have I no no
you never would have no this it's funny
how this how this dress came about was
um we saw a girl at mannequins that had
it on yeah and Tom was like ooh I think
I like that and it's like I think that
would look really good on you so he goes
up to this is what he does like to girls
all the time if they're wearing like
like a cool outfit they like they he
always goes up and he's like where did
you get that like you know I want to get
that from I want to get that for my
girlfriend and so like and most people
are like really loving yeah then the
girls love it yeah yeah so she told me
what you got she got it from Sheen yeah
it's an app you download yeah that dress
was ten dollars
yeah ten dollars subsequently we saw
another one we got all kinds of [__] on
there another woman at mannequins with
the same dress on yeah although I didn't
immediately know it was the same one
because she had a waist Center on over
it and I think the other girl was like
what's it I mean you could dress it up
like different ways
to him well my corset's not today that's
why it's tight enough it's tight enough
it looks all right well I don't I don't
really this is not we're talking about
it it's not authorized it's hot yeah
yeah yeah it's just move yeah back up
back up as much as you can so they can
see yeah it's like yeah yeah it turns
out with yeah
yeah that shit's slit it all the way up
to here it looks really good other side
too tell me what is that why it looks
the same
that's a hot dress I like it I'm glad
that I went out of my way to go attack
that other woman says where'd you get
that dress because you never believe
where I got this dress and she said you
never believe how much I paid for it and
I said no [__] and she just it was ten
dollars I was like what she goes yeah it
was and then she goes
I've friended her on
Instagram and she goes I'll send you the
link I said okay okay okay
she went from here she was from out of
town
next day [__] I said Hey where's the
lake she sent me the link back and she
goes you got to get this app before you
could actually it's just a Chinese
[__]
store called shin
and they got all kinds of stuff yeah if
we were looking on there last night man
they got all kinds of stuff they got a
golf section they got like a pump punk
rock section A Fairy core section of uh
all and it's got a lot of [__] on there
and it's look it's not high dollar stuff
it's
basic stuff yeah yeah like stockings and
bras but if you're looking to build a
build a big wardrobe a wardrobe quickly
for not a lot of money then that's right
that's where you go clothes probably
aren't going to last that long but you
know what I mean most of the girl well
the girls on there will take a picture
when they get it and wear it and then
they'll tell you if the quality is good
some you know and so far most of the
feedback people said this quality is
good God is good for what it is it's
just Overstock stuff and yeah stuff that
but they had a lot of really nice [__]
really a lot of yeah it's not you're not
talking about Black Rose or [__] you
know or with another company Shrine you
know that's what we're talking about
it's just Club close
and they even have demonia knockoff
boots
they say the the platter is not quite as
thick but they get the job done for 30
40 bucks instead of 100 bucks you know
it's that kind of stuff
Julian said it would be cool to see a
Sidetrack show where you're also cooking
something from your cookbook we'll have
to do that one of these days especially
now that we have that little bitty
camera
yeah the action cam
you can't live stream from it though
not unless it's on a Wire
we have to bring it in it's doing
cooking shows live is very difficult and
the lighting has to be just right
because food looks like [__] on video
unless Well everybody's perfect it just
looks terrible which is hilarious go try
to take a photograph of a pizza and you
tell me if you'd eat that
you can take a photo should ever people
do it every day they post like pictures
of their food all over Instagram and
Tick Tock and stuff there is a food
setting yeah and I think I think they're
using that a lot
um it's probably better than it used to
be but it used to be taking a picture of
a [__] Pizza Man
look like a [__]
okay look like a stain or something just
a yellow round top of a zit or something
yeah it is very hard I mean that's why
that's a whole like specialty you know
what I mean yeah like food photographers
yeah most of those photographs of food
that you're seeing are not food
like the ice cream is always Crisco
well like I said at least I don't know
about uh you know as far as photographs
go but I know that as far as uh video
advertising TV commercials stuff like
that
um the thing that you're advertising
like say if you're Breyers and you're
doing an ice cream commercial you have
to show the ice cream in there like
other stuff can be fake you know what I
mean but um the thing that you're
showing I think legally it has to
remember that uh when they were showing
[__] like ranch dressing being poured
slowly in a television commercial that
that's not rice dressing that that's
white house paint latex paint well now
[__] green flakes one thing that they
do that they can get away with that I've
heard
in a cereal commercial like they have to
show the actual cereal but because
they're not selling the milk the milk
can just be like Elmer's glue or
something like that you know what I mean
yeah but the cereal has to be real Yeah
well yeah because when you photograph
milk or it like has a weird bluish tinge
yeah like the milk and Star Wars
and they're showing stuff in slow motion
sometimes you don't realize that it's in
slow motion but they'll show The Milk
porn in slow motion slightly and real
milk doesn't look good [__] flowing
in slow motion but maybe Elmer's Glue
would look a lot better well yeah
because it has more thicker richer yeah
more viscosity right
Camp guy said they airbrush a bunch of
subliminal stuff yeah they probably do
they used to yeah I mean
man he's talking about all this stuff
that was you know like airbrushing in
the subliminal [__] and that all this uh
which was really artistic they had a
higher artists back then to do just like
a a [__] cigarette poster your [__]
was real well done you know
but I was seeing this program uh last
night it was on Event Horizon and they
had a guy who was in in this big AI
approach project and he knows exactly
the state of AI of artificial
intelligence and it's way ahead of what
I thought he said this thing would
probably will surpass probably surpass
humans within months maybe three years
and it's better at things that they
never guessed it would be good at
um they have a bunch of different ones
that they're working with
but he says the shit's scary he's
working on it he says yeah it's scary we
need to watch it because we shouldn't
give this thing any power like you don't
want to give it control of [__]
nuclear weapons or anything yeah we've
all seen Terminator yeah it would do
things like well they have IAI too so
you know what to be faster than that I'm
gonna go ahead and launch it would do
things like that
um but they're what's what's weird is
that what this AI is good at is exactly
the opposite of what we're expecting
it's good at Art and philosophy and
conversational stuff and
um things that were like uniquely human
that's what it's good at it's good at
high level executive management
this thing could get rid of a CEO it
would get rid of all office workers
everything
um
any kind of [__] interior designer
any sales manager it could get rid of
it'll get rid and replace everybody
you said the only thing
and this is a dude you can go watch your
event horizon it's a good Channel on
YouTube he's got all these guests that
are from from all from the Science World
and he said uh people are always worried
about well all this manual labor is
going to be obsolete because a robots is
no
no all the intellectual shit's going to
go obsolete because of AI will not go
obsolete is manual labor
things like pick and fruit painting the
houses
digging pipes fixing stuff fixing broken
stuff
and it just just said that the
janitorial work
all that shit's safe when this AI comes
out and they start putting it in charge
of [__] it's going to be devastating
I don't know what's going to happen I
think it's going to be just like in Dune
they're going to have the butlerian
Jihad where they're going to make it
illegal to do a uh
they had a I think it's doing it's
making artwork and it does amazing art
Zach says I've been playing with an AI
music thing Google just dropped yeah I
was hearing about that I haven't played
with it yet but yeah um he said it's
really cool but it only produces 19
second Clips so far yeah I think like if
you there's ones that you can pay for
that will um come up with songs but I've
never really heard anything that it
produced so I'm not really sure it'll
probably get rid of all [__] cam work
and porn stars because it uh it will
have the ability to fake a video image
of a of a of a porn act
and you would believe it evidently
that's just that's how good it is that
you would believe that that was a real
person and they could do it in all
different kind of formats to make it
look like a low res video or to make it
look like old 70s film that it could
fake any image and make characters that
are accurate and then you could talk to
them live and they would interact with
you
so they could
you wouldn't know it but you'd be
talking to an AI cam girl it's a total
it's just a robot
that's how good it is they said the
conversation is very good
it said that the robotics is that's
actually behind the AI stuff
yeah but once they have the robotics
that shit's going to replace humans
or be a threat to a human
it could replace you
I wouldn't want that
I've been messing around with uh what is
AI art programs it comes up with some
cool [__] like some of the stuff it
comes up with it's still not depending
on what filter you use
um it's still not super good at humans
but you know like doing human faces that
don't look unsettling yeah but um some
of the shit's pretty good though yeah
but see that's the thing I'm not really
sure like if you don't put a source
photo in which sometimes I don't because
I want to see how it comes out but
um I'm not entirely sure like where it's
drawing some of this no where it's
drawing like the images from okay you
know what I mean this guy is uh I I
forgot what I think it's MIT or or it
has something to do with Harvard I think
it's it's like the top
it's the top AI
thing going on and they have about four
or five different computers that they're
working with and they're each one's
different
but
so he said some of them are just ready
to go
and that they're going to exceed humans
he's kind of worried about it and he
knows that he's working on it and
they're kind of worried about it
well I don't know I don't worry about
this teaching myself because one there's
nothing I can do about it and two I just
tell myself going back through history
like people have always worried about
like new technology and [__] and most of
the time we just adapted to it
eventually well they had it read in
parts of the internet
and uh they were trying to get it to do
like [__] law thesis and [__] like
that and it would start not only doing
law but then other things that they
didn't expect like you know it's also
talking about philosophy yeah it starts
going into other things it's learning
it's actually teaching itself
and they don't really
and and God was amazed he says well you
know
in biology and human evolution we're
talking about how
you know you know how difficult it was
to for for intelligence to uh occur in
in humans and he says maybe uh what
we're seeing now probably no not in Pro
not not difficult to do at all uh this
simple this basically simple AI
algorithm is [__] doing it
you know it has a lot of complicated
little subroutines and stuff but uh it's
it's doing a much better job and it's
doing a lot faster it's evolving whether
or not it's conscious I don't think so
I think it has to have Quantum Computing
involved in other words to give it like
a sense of being but it's virtually
conscious I would think
it would tell you that it was
Tammy said they had some college kids
use AI to write their papers for them
yeah they have all that stuff on like
those article Spinners and stuff like
that where you can just like have it
compile a bunch of information from a
bunch of different sites in it
spits out like you have to still read it
because sometimes it says some weird
[__] but yeah a lot of news articles
were that
from well the unknown newspapers like
random newspapers that you find you'd
see an article in there and it was just
sourcing it was just quoting other
articles and re re-jumbling it around
you know thank you Jeffy art that's why
because
um that's one of the way they're like oh
that's how you you know make money with
like a blog like a news blog or
something like that and you can have an
article spinner
um you know AI do the work for you you
basically say I want to write an article
about this and it'll pull from all these
different things and like I said you
still have to read through it because a
lot of times I'm reading it going yeah
my little grammar Nazi brain is going Ah
that's not right
but evidently the way of The Cutting
Edge [__] is [__] awesome though
right now we don't have access to The
Cutting Edge [__] just they just they do
I mean the [__] that they have now is
pretty good but the the thing too is
that a lot of times
um the real good [__] is like behind a
paywall you know what I mean like any
kind of AI because there's a million
different kinds there's music ones
there's art ones there's you know paper
writing ones there's all that kind of
stuff but
um usually they'll only let you have
like the kind of laymash [__] for free
yeah and then you got to pay like a
monthly fee for you the ones that these
guys are dealing with I don't think you
can pay to access them I think it's just
Scholars and scientists dealing with it
I don't and he didn't say it was
available in the public I don't believe
but he said it was good he said it was
real good
it's doing science it's doing physics
and [__] well I mean I've been pretty
impressed with just like the stuff that
they have out
just that's available to the public so I
can imagine
that it's probably like a lot better
than we know about
um what was I was gonna say something
then I forgot what it was
uh oh
so Xander does sent us movies right yeah
we haven't seen him yet though and uh
the professional and the professional so
yeah and the professional has the French
edit on it too that I want to see yeah
so that's one of the movies that we'll
be talking about on Sunday yeah I have
to say though because I think somebody
brought it up on Wednesday night's
stream they asked about uh terrifier too
and I forgot to mention that we actually
did watch that because they added it on
um Amazon Prime yeah so it's good I was
like yeah I actually really liked it
well the thing about it was that I mean
we loved the first terrifier and I
really liked um uh All Hallows Eve too
which was the first appearance of art
the clown that what was that from that
was from 2013 I want to say that was
like a anthology
but um I guess because I had heard so
much about terrifyer too and it's like
everybody's like oh my God it's the
goriest thing ever so I was kind of just
ex I don't know why I expected this but
I was expecting it to just I heard too
that it was like long it's like two
hours so I was like expecting it to be
just like this two-hour con like
continuous bloodbath and it's really not
like that there's actually like kind of
characters and like a good story and
[__] like that and then there's kind of
like occasionally like pretty cool and
honestly it wasn't that's not that
gorgeous it wasn't nearly as gory as I
was expecting like it had a couple
things where I was like ah damn you know
what I mean but it wasn't like holy [__]
I can't watch it you know what I mean
the level was just right yeah yeah
because I heard like some people saying
it's like oh I'm into gory movies but
man I couldn't handle that I'm like man
what was he
it wasn't that bad but then you make me
that uncomfortable it wasn't that bad
Human Centipede made me a lot more
uncomfortable well see I've said this
before like I can handle all that kind
of Gore and broken Limbs and all that
could be heading and all that kind of
stuff that doesn't bother me at all like
in movies but but the second you start
[__] in someone's mouth or making
someone drink vomit or something like
that I'm like yeah I'm out yeah I'm out
I mean I did a review of a book
other day if you saw it like a novella
which was called 100 match and um that
[__] it wasn't the grossest [__] I ever
read but that was the more the kind of
[__] that I find like really disgusting
like hey here's this guy who's just like
a total scumbag and he works at a fast
food place and he like shits in a bag
and then like puts it in the chili and
like serves it to people and stuff like
that kind of stuff like grocery you
gotta go go to work all right man we'll
see you later okay have fun yeah
hey
yeah we were just talking about Skynet
and everything I said yeah everybody saw
Charming yeah we know what's gonna
happen it's all right whatever I was
like I said I can't do anything about it
so I'm not particularly worried about it
I tend to I tend to just worry about
[__] I can do stuff
the danger is is that it'll get rid of
anything having to do with the
professional office eventually
Office Buildings cities because cities
are the life support of the office
building that's why the for the city is
there to support the office building
those are all endangered uh because the
jobs are endangered you go down downtown
Orlando and look at this big [__]
bank skyscrapers that have been there
since the 80s
those are mostly empty now
the offices are empty government
buildings are mostly empty because they
were built
back when people had typewriters
teletypes and [__] like that where you
needed a hundred 150 people in an office
to get something done well those 150
people are all replaced with two laptops
two people and two laptops so you don't
need all that empty space good out of
Washington DC it's empty it's like a
monument to the Past
to just
you know I don't even think they go to
show up to work I think they all work
from home on laptops
but it wouldn't matter because
those offices were built for back in the
day when they had typewriters
that shit's gone
said I had mixed feelings on terrifier
too the gore was more funny in an in
your face sort of way yeah it did kind
of go it was one of those things and I
found this with a lot of movies that are
like super super gory is that once it
goes past a certain threshold it just
becomes funny to me you know what I mean
just sending us money thank you gadget3
I love you too half pissed and my phone
that means drunk yeah in in in British
in British English yeah uh and my phone
reminded me it's Friday my niece's
preggo cat had six babies ah my one is
called Hobbs ah as in Calvin and that's
pretty cute okay oh you got it Katie
Zach says I'm just excited for AI to
make life easier for us depending on the
task yeah it's like just like any other
new technology like I said I'm not super
worried about it yeah I'm sure it's
gonna have like a lot of unforeseen
consequences but it might have like some
unforeseen benefits as well so I'm just
I don't know I don't have a bigger
impact I think I'm reserving judgment
it's going to have a bigger impact than
even the internet
yeah I'm sure it is I'm just saying that
I'm just waiting to see what happens
because like I said it's not like I can
[__] do anything about it so I'm just
kind of sitting back and
waiting to see what goes on with it in
the meantime I'm kind of having fun
farting around with uh yeah so it could
be two jobs available once AI takes over
janitor and hooker that's it that's the
only
and then then the hookers are going to
have to make do with janitor's salaries
be funny well I mean once they have like
robots that can do all that kind of
stuff then we won't even need I have a
feeling that that you'd have
uh pleasure robots well that's like the
first thing they would make what are you
talking about they're already trying to
make them basically the same well yeah
that's what I mean it'd be easy I think
to just put a robotic chassis in there
and then with the AI they're talking
about it's it's language capability is
supposed to be really good yeah so it'd
be just like a real person pretty much
which I would think that the person
probably wouldn't want that
I don't know I feel like probably they
would just want to be like a porn star
not a real person a real person like
give me the [__] out of here you fat
mother
I wanted to just be a [__] program
bro porn star but um
I I think I think it would go out of
style real quick
they'll be like that's not a real woman
it'd be like that I think it would
probably
it would probably be uh like much higher
Prestige to have a real girlfriend
because look
s look I'm kind of on a smaller scale
with you know with the proliferation of
the internet and all this other kind of
and you know streaming media and all
this other kind of stuff there was a not
insignificant subset of the population
who got all into like old [__] yeah like
started buying vinyl records again and
like and building tables out of wood and
[__] like that like getting back into
doing that kind of stuff so I think
there's always going to be that drive in
humans to not like if it goes too far in
One Direction they're gonna go let's go
back and like do this hard I'm feeling a
guy would probably buy something like
that like in that movie Cherry 2000 he
might have something like that but he'd
probably get bored with it pretty quick
would you buy one yeah
baby you're probably getting bored with
it real quick what would it look like I
don't know just you could wait I would
want one you could make it look like
anything you wanted
you know what I mean
be modular you could change its looks
oh yeah you could make it like Mr Potato
Head yeah like Mr Potato Head yeah
you have a sex pot that looks like Mr
Potato I bet in the sense that you could
pull its arms and legs and head off and
play different stuff I think yeah we try
to snap a different face on there we
talked about it before I don't think I'd
be comfortable with one that was trying
to look like a human
you know I mean that would be kind of
weird I think it'd be too creepy it'd
like having a dead body in the house
that moved around
I wouldn't like it yeah that yeah it
would be a little unsettling I'd
probably be a lot better if it was like
you know something like out of anime
where it was you know bright blue and it
lit up and yeah it looks kind of like
yeah it looked like something out of a
casino you know what I mean it glowed
and you know something with like yeah
and it was so [__] voluptuous it's
outside human possibility you know what
I mean or that kind of thing you know or
the legs are far too long on it you know
what I mean no no human could have legs
that long you know because why would it
why would you be
Bound by biology and reality if you're
making something like that go straight
fantasy yeah you could just make
whatever you wanted it would be it'd be
like a
if you ever see that [__] hentai
Japanese cartoons and [__] I mean the
the proportions are insane not possible
but they'd be possible for a robot
something that's not alive
you know
like I got to they got Japanese cartoon
porn that just fixates all fat girls but
no fat girl could actually be shaped
like that
a fat girl with a [__] waist like
this you know what I mean yeah tiny
waist and huge hips and huge bust that's
not possible you know
each breast the size of a [__]
basketball
no [__] that beach ball
beach ball
you know did you know [__]
areola's the size of dinner plates you
know that's not possible
yeah but then they say then the face is
like the face of a skinny girl no it's
not gonna happen
well no but you know some people like
only in cartoons sure well like I said
that's the fun of cartoons and that's
the fun of yeah [__] around with that
kind of stuff is that it doesn't have to
look real yeah it can look like I would
think that that's probably the way a lot
of sex bots would go
the market would be driven to some kind
of extremes
probably well like I said we when we
were scrolling through
the dildo selection yeah uh to get some
props for the for the show uh not this
show obviously but um I like that they
have like a whole line of what they call
them like monster yeah they call them
like monster dicks yeah yeah so they do
have ones that are like because I think
I showed that one like on Wednesday but
um that I can't really even remember
what that one was called space dragon
and they have one that just like is a
straight up tentacle too it's like the
same colors it's like blue and purple
it's really pretty actually because I
was like I kind of like the idea of
they're going through Lovecraft [__]
yeah yeah I really like the Lovecraft
ones but um
well because you can put those on your
coffee table
and they're decorative like they're not
I mean everyone's gonna know it's a
dildo they're like why do you have
dildos on your coffee but I'm just
saying that you know you could just have
them out and they're cool looking like
art objects that's why I don't really
like I've never been a big fan of like
the the ones that are like super
realistic I really don't like those I
think they're even though like I said
yeah like like real dicks are real dicks
are fine but it's like I don't really
want a super realistic dick like sitting
around the house like just all
disembodied and stuff that's like a
whole bucket full of them right that's
like really freaky to me
it's like I don't really like a whole
bucket I like ones that are like weird
like or look like art objects kind of
yeah clear one yeah we have like yeah we
have like one that's clear we have one
that's like just like like glossy black
and then we have one that's like red and
black yeah but they have all kind of
like crazy looking ones and they're
really cool like they have monster ones
like in all different colors they look
kind of like on camera yeah well the one
that I have the eyeshadowed like that
blue and purple one that has like all
the weird
stuff it kind of reminded me of do you
remember like back in the 80s and 90s
there was that big rage for those weird
like those candles yeah that were like
carved and they were like all curly and
they were all stripy they like they
looked like that stripy like ribbon
candy like it kind of reminded me of
that and I'm like I'm into that like I
just it's not um I'm gonna say it's not
like super practical or super functional
in the way that it's supposed to be
functional
um but but it looks cool anyway you know
what I mean it's it's functional enough
now I have I had but I have a feeling
that the um
sex bots would be a rage but it probably
wouldn't last long
it would be like a fad
yeah see I kind of feel like that's why
I don't get like all upset or
outraged or like that about anything
that's like oh this new techno oh it's a
downfall of humanity I'm like yeah they
said that about every [__] thing that
came along and we're still trucking so
yeah I'm not passes that's what I mean
it's like [__] never works out the way
everybody thinks it's going to and all
of these like chicken little people that
are just like oh my God this guy's
probably it's just like they just look
stupid
I don't think Sky would fall with sex
bots well no I'm not talking about that
I don't think would stop dudes from
getting married or anything like that no
not really they're not really getting
married as it is well the thing about a
sex spot is just that I mean I guess you
could argue if it's like realistic
enough it's almost kind of like cheating
but really it's just kind of like a
really realistic sex toy yeah that's
exactly and here's the thing and you can
just watch them you go to go walk around
in public with obviously a sex toy some
people would
take I'm gonna take my sex bot to the
grocery store she's gonna help me I'm
gonna take Vanessa too I'm gonna I'm
gonna put her in the car like you're
bringing that in the cart oh my God we
should totally do
once we start the channel yeah wouldn't
that be [__] hilarious yeah if we got
like if we had if we were raking in
enough money to get like a real doll or
something right because it was fun yeah
yeah yeah and we'll just like we'll put
her in the cart and we'll just like walk
around like like it's totally normal I
think it happens and see if anybody
thinks it happens something like that
would eventually become synonymous with
like being a loser that's probably what
it would probably end up being a social
pod to have some [__] like that well I
kind of because I kind of feel like it
already has that stigma about it because
look if you're a dude that paid how much
for sex how much are real dolls they're
alive 1800 I think yeah they're like a
couple Grand I thought
um you know and they are realistic but
they still are kind of uncanny valley
looking in my opinion I haven't seen
them in a while maybe they're better now
but it's just kind of like you're trying
to make it look too real yeah but like
if you knew a dude and he said yeah I've
got one of those like you would just be
like bro yeah like a dude like why'd you
spend all that money like on it it seems
like a weird thing and it's not weird to
me like for people to spend money on sex
toys that are kind of like you know like
like you know if a dude has a flashlight
or something like for example that's not
weird like a lot of people have those
but like when you get to a point where
you're paying thousands of dollars for
something that looks super super
realistic yeah like it's you're missing
something in your life I'm just kind of
like are you sitting in your house
talking to them like it's real or maybe
not but it's maybe that's not fair but I
was like what do you do with her when
you're not using her do you just like
stuff her in the closet or do you now I
might not know what I'm talking about
you might buy one of these things
and it's kind of like having a person in
your house but they're they're hilarious
while you're not having sex with it it's
running around and it's entertaining as
[__] it might be saying funny [__] you
don't know it might be hilarious
because there's probably a personality
modes
you know we're a little okay this we're
gonna make it fun and we're gonna let it
go but does that take the fun out of it
that you have control over it that you
can dictate I think it might be a fun
thing and we're gonna we're gonna let
her run around and do whatever she wants
to do and she's just doing stupid [__]
you know because I think most of the fun
of interacting with humans is you don't
know yeah you don't control that person
so you don't really know what they're
gonna do exactly but then they might say
okay then what we're gonna do is be
we're gonna make sure you can't control
this thing so it's fun so it's like a
wild card it's like yeah here just take
it we don't it's it's it's set you just
gotta live with it
so it might be that
I'm sure these dudes are [__]
Geniuses at marketing they're gonna [__]
you they're gonna [__] you up so they're
gonna figure out what makes a dude tick
and they're gonna go for his weaknesses
and come at you with this [__] might
be this delightful little [__] chick
that looks real
and [__] you get convinced that she's
real like Joy from [__] that's what I
was thinking from Blade Runners
she was just a she was just a hologram
yeah he should have known better
he wasn't real either though he was a
replicant yeah which was kind of real
more real than a hologram as a person
yeah replicants were people
they just weren't naturally created
right it was kind of artificially but
yeah like yeah she was a hologram like
he could put her like on a little yeah
like a little memory stick she seemed to
be real yeah she had feelings for her
and [__] and then when the when when he
he go he goes downtown and the uh
he's a Blade Runner he's a [__]
replicant Blade Runner and they had some
replica hookers make a move on him and
when that [__] little Joy device
called him and she was oh you don't like
real girls that it was like a for Paw
that right his girlfriend was a hologram
right that some dudes were buying these
Holograms
like I said I can kind of feel like and
there have been a couple other than
Blade Runner 2049 there have been a
couple of other movies I feel like like
dudes that fell in love with like AI
women like I think there was one called
her that where a dude fell in love with
like a what I think she was like on a
phone like she was an app on a phone or
something like that
um and yeah they're always kind of
portrayed as
there's something a little bit wrong
with them you know what I mean
well what was weird about uh what was
what was uh
what was the Blade Runner's name from
Blade Runner uh Joe
what's his name Jeff yeah well that's
what they call them yeah yeah they call
it a Joe but she called everybody Joe
too Joe was just a generic name weren't
you wouldn't she just program to call
him Joe uh I told everybody I don't
actually remember Joy did
she was generic also but he eventually
realized that she wasn't real remember
that and that's when he had his
breakthrough moment yeah he gave his
life to [__] deliver the
what was it the uh the information the
Decker about where the memories had come
from which was his daughter yeah
a half replicant or maybe totally
replicant daughter I the way I
read it is that they were both
replicates
because uh who was it
not Weyland what was the name of the uh
Wallace Wallace Corporation wanted
replicants that could multiply
ever yeah rail started it yeah
grampers asked uh when the new show
starts
so
this weekend we were just talking about
this earlier this weekend like I said we
have a bunch of footage I have to edit
it together still we did like some
footage and we did some photos I gotta
edit those and fix those up and
everything like that this weekend we
want to shoot some more stuff but we
were talking today that you know it's
good to do all the video footage and
stuff so we can have some clips up there
to sell but we think that the real money
is going to be in the live stream just
like on uh stream mate so I was like
probably we need to start that sooner
rather than later and just kind of like
test the waters and see
um what's like you know what's the
income possibilities right and just see
what the income possibilities are so I
kind of feel like maybe not maybe not
this weekend but maybe like next maybe
like next Saturday night or something
like that we should like try it out do
you think or is that too soon maybe too
soon we have to get
here's the thing we don't want to open
streammate
until we have products to sell
Gotta Have photos and we need at least
three or four videos
and those are going to go up on other
platforms too we've got to look at
streammates policies sometimes they
don't evidently they don't like cross
promotion
and they don't if you give them a video
and you're selling it through them it
might have to be exclusive to them
which means we might have to have more
than one edit
of that video so we can sell songs other
places because we want there's a couple
other platforms
now my friends in the industry
Quinn
he said
when it comes to video sales
if let's say you're looking to make a
thousand dollars a month just on video
sales
you're going to need about 100 150 good
videos on all those platforms running
all simultaneously and you'll get
um
residual money of about a thousand a
month that was the deal like I wanted to
make a thousand a thousand a month just
in videos like what does it take
about 150 videos
because it's law of averages yeah you
have to cast a wide net you have to have
good content it has to be on all the
platforms you can go
that you can be on so
video is not the main earner
main earner
for us is going to be streamate
because uh
even even an okay channel can make a
thousand a week
on stream big
if you're doing uh 30 40 hours a week
yeah I mean you have to it's just like
anything else you actually put the work
in yeah but like without a stream solid
you just have to put in hours yeah
and um a lot of the players are also not
only doing stream mate they're saying
[__] it they'll jump over to another one
called Chatterbait
which is just wide open like Coliseum
but they're having just basically a talk
show over there if it's couples some of
them are just wild just having sex but
that's like almost usury because you'd
be a watch by five six thousand people
and only four or five of them are paid
yeah I'm not doing that [__] yeah it
might add up you know what I mean an
hour it might be [__] three four
hundred bucks but
depending on exactly what happens but
man it's a lot of free people you know
there's a lot of people up there just
seeing [__] for free
but they have some couples do real well
on on on open sites like that
and they're doing well and it's not
really just sex they're entertaining
and people are sending them tips for you
know girls [__] titty flashing and
[__] just real stupid [__] yeah but it's
funny
you got to be entertaining and me and
Jen can you know we can ad-lib
and if we're not handcuffed
and YouTube handcuffs you about what it
is you can talk about you'll get
demonetized you know
these places are x-rated you can say
whatever you want
so it would we could be actually a
little bit more entertaining over there
that's just one idea you want to stream
on several platforms live Jasmine
what's up
Sex Panther
they say that one's pretty good but I
don't know if they had little allow
couples on it we have to figure out
which one yeah some of them are just
like
um singles only or some of them are
women only I think yeah or yeah some of
them don't do couples but you know
but from every from all our research
that we did it seemed like streamate was
the best it's like the best one overall
like for what we want to do yeah
um you know so grandpar's asked will it
be weird having some dude in Belgium
telling you what they want to see
not really because everybody had to be
on a screen like it does we don't know
where they're from yeah we don't really
care and it's just kind of like as long
as they don't tell me to do anything
great with something I'm really that
worried about it you see the way the way
it works on stream mate
the people watching can can speak in
public
the public show
can't be x-rated you can't do anything
in public
it can be R-rated but it can't really be
X-rated
the people can speak the people watching
can speak in public by typing out and
every everybody else watching can see or
they can text in private so you can
start private negotiations through the
chats if they want to go private
there's a bunch of different rules like
you could set hourly per minute like
4.99 per minute
and they may want something real quick
but they're only going to be there like
three four minutes
five minutes as long as it takes like
right right now
that's one way you can do it you can
also do things like okay we're going to
start countdown for a gold show a
[__] uh gold show eat one gold is
Oracle one dollar all right go the show
will be you can set the parameters
show will be an hour long we'll start
the show when we reach 400 dollars
um
and then it count down you set the
countdown if you reach 400 dollars
you can still let it roll
and then you can start to show the
people that paid get to watch
during the show they can interact
there's a bunch of [__] you can let them
do you can you can you can let them go
cam to cam but it costs money so you can
see them too they can also send audio
in other words they talk to you live
over the camera the only people that are
seeing that are people that pay to see
the show yeah they don't get a bunch of
freeloaders but you can change the
parameters of the show so some of that
stuff can't happen like we don't want
cam to cam all right
you know yeah I don't know how I feel
about that I mean we'll see we'll see
when we get into it like I wouldn't mind
if it was somebody that you know was a
regular it was like usual stuff but yeah
but it's like you just have some Rando
wandering and it's like [__] I don't
know you and I don't know if I wanna
comes on his [__] job of the Hutt and
the [__] crawling back into the
[__] you don't want to see that right
that's what I mean it's like well that
just yeah you're like shut us over that
just made my lady yeah so you know you
know you know so you can you can yeah
you don't have to do any of that
um yeah they seem pretty like I mean you
can it's your stream so you can pretty
much do you do what you want what you
want when you start in the gold show you
can say this is what's going to happen
in the show we're going to do this we're
gonna [__] do toys we're gonna make
out we're gonna do which I'm gonna get
ahead we're gonna do this all right it's
Gonna Last an hour and it's going to be
open we'll we'll be able to talk
um
different ways you can do the camera you
change settings there's all kinds of
change the sets
so it's
it's uh you know
it's kind of natural
the way it's going
I guess that's what you want to call it
if you've ever seen anybody's recorded
gold shows it's just it's like this
pretty much hold on let me move the
camera all right yeah it's pretty
informal yeah yeah
which I think is what people like about
it because it's just like regular people
but you're getting to see them like do
some stuff right you don't get to see
Regular People yeah and during the gold
show they're also tipping
some guys are tipping like they got a
request Jenny could you do this and that
blow him okay here here's 20. you know
okay can do just [__] like that granther
says 30 to 40 hours a week my skin would
peel off uh I'd have to get a script for
uh see Alice to do this no sometimes but
the thing about it is that all says is
that you're not just [__] the whole
time most of the time you're just like
talking talking and waiting and just
waiting for people to do stuff and just
kind of like teasing around or like just
like entertaining people because I kind
of feel like a lot of times because like
I said we watched some recorded
uh you know streammates and most of the
time like and some of them were you know
solo shows which was just a girl but
most of the time they were just like
talking and just like hanging out with
the people hey what's your face like how
are you doing like a lot of regulars
yeah so because they have the same like
they have fans just like everybody else
so it's like they just kind of talk to
them and stuff so they're not doing [__]
the whole time yeah no it's just like
this yeah like a lot of the times it's
just like this where they're just
hanging out and talking talking about
their wives and [__] crying about the
wife there's all kinds of stuff you know
she knows the wives the the girl knows
the wife's name oh yeah she did that man
[__] that yeah how's Gladys doing these
days what a [__]
pop my titties out you ready to jerk off
so it's it's
um it's not just [__] helping dudes
jerk off right really it's more of like
[__]
it's almost kind of like [__] being a
guidance counselor kind of it's like
it's like therapy like cheap there yeah
they have uh
the the act on when it goes the stream
mate
the um the average customer
is middle-aged dude
uh married
not really having sex with his wife
that's the average he's got a credit
card he's bored all right he's nobody's
talking to him that's that's what it is
that's the average guy yeah
so they just like
I mean you know it's it's understandable
like the guy's just like hey I'm gonna
go in this room and this
hot girl is gonna talk to me yeah and
like kind of pretend to be my friend
well it's not saying pretend to be your
friend I think they are friends maybe
they are like after a while
they do kind of um you know make friends
with some of the people that are there
was one cam girl we saw I saw a
interview with her she got to know one
of the guys and she went to his
daughter's graduation she knew the wife
and everything the wife knew who she was
but it was just one of the ones that
over the years that she collected like I
said how weird would that be yeah
showing up it's like Dream Maker oh
here's my wife I know here's the girl
that I jerk off to yeah and I can't get
anything from you yeah right so you know
what I mean
I can imagine yeah
I don't know see I I don't know how I
would react
some women shut the husband off though
you know menopause hits them they get
shut off right I get that and she don't
care what he does but I'm just I get
that so maybe that's how that works yeah
I shouldn't care I mean I guess she
doesn't care because like otherwise why
would she have allowed that although
yeah you're projecting your right no I'm
just wondering no I'm just a lot of
these women don't want to [__] that dude
they're sick of [__] that dude they
don't want to lose him
because of the security and it's like
the husband you know I mean she's like
yes you yes you plea please jerk off to
her
just leave me alone leave me the [__]
alone
that's exactly what's going on that's
what Mistresses were all about a lot of
times Mr Susan hookers are that's what
it is yeah you know like that girl Ayla
she says that the average dude is like
65 and he hasn't been laid by the wife
in a decade she that she totally shut
him off just no interest in him and she
knows and she doesn't care she's like
thankful oh good good go have fun with
her yeah because
that wife knows that her 65 year old
husband isn't going to run off with some
[__] 25 year old hooker
you know as much as he might feel
excited about it she makes Yale it makes
about a million a year in hooker money
all right well hey hook your money is
the same and that is that old [__]
diabetes [__] what's the other
dude who's the actor from willferry yeah
that's who you're talking about Wilford
Brimley is his name yeah Wilford Brimley
[__] you know she's got a
hundred of those
yeah why is she gonna choose him over
the other [__] 99
well and like I said if she was gonna
choose somebody like as a life partner
or something like that obviously she
would choose someone more her own age
probably yeah she'll well she don't want
to like it she keeps four or five of
those at her house right
guys her age and she says she had to she
has to kick him out and and start
coaches and [__] and start over because
they start becoming parasitical on her
well yeah I'm sure they just lay around
places
don't clean up yeah and then you stop
listening I can imagine she fires him
and just replaces them with other ones
you know what happens when a bunch of
dudes all yep live in a place yeah no
she's open soon looks like a pig she's
intelligent she's good looking she looks
like
lit what's it lift tape lift Campbell
another [__] Stephen Tyler's house
Tyler Stephen Tyler's daughter daughter
Liv Tyler's her name husband daughter
wife whatever the [__] they are nephew
great grandmother she looks like that
but she had plaque cosmetic surgery done
she's pretty intelligent came out of a
Christian cult
became a cam girl first and got made a
lot of money as a cab girl got burned
out just became an escort
but and she makes a [__] ton of money as
an escort and she's got Twitter and
she's on all the [__] intellectual
circles and [__]
but uh
I follow her on Twitter she says okay
she's doing surveys she says [__]
funny [__] one of the things that she
posted was a photograph that was
supposed to be poking fun at her
customers and it was all them [__] 65
year old friendly brimble [__]
died be this [__] on a farm
[__] side by side going you sure are
interesting just it was just so funny
tell her you sure are interesting and
you know and
and the other hookers were laughing at
him not really you know it's not that
they're yeah it's you know you can't
really just laugh at the people because
they're paying your they're paying your
bills they're just kind of teasing the
fact that their customers are old yeah
that's who has that money
Yeah well yeah that's who has the
disposable income to be just like thrown
away on [__] like that she said she
went low end
all right for younger guy younger
customers so they treat you like [__]
yeah no I don't know so she just raised
her price to even
get in the door with her the first hour
is 1800.
I don't blame her yeah and it's 6 000 a
day like I said you need yeah you can't
like if you um just go for like the
low-hanging fruit and [__] like that
when she raised when she raised her
price she had to work less and got more
money and [__] uh got Trina better
I believe it but it was old men
yeah I mean but that's okay I would
rather I mean you know I'm not into the
old men or anything like that neither
are they but yeah well yeah I'm just
saying that
um you know there's a lot to be said for
people that actually uh treat you with
some modicum respect she she I saw an
interview with her on YouTube she was
saying that and [__] I sent that I
sent piece that interviewed or I told
either I sent the interview to Sophie
all right or I mentioned it to her and
she she was laughing she goes yeah women
have a special power but
[__] Ayla said that she was so says
she's so Twisted her psychology she
criticizes herself she said her
psychology is so twisted
that she is able
to get off on how ugly a [__] is
and how what a mismatch he is versus her
in other words he's way too old way too
ugly just [__] up and next to her next
to her she looks like a goddess and
she's getting off on that
I get that yeah I don't know if I could
do it but I get how people could do that
yeah so so she she's like I said her
barrier to ugly she has a mental
strategy
off on getting off on how ugly some dude
is I'm not well the weird thing about it
and I think I've said this before but
it's like I'm not really I don't know I
don't really make that distinction
because like I said if you're physically
ugly that doesn't necessarily mean like
if you're like a really awesome person
then you seem less ugly
you know what I mean that's what she was
saying no I know that but I'm just
saying no I'm saying that's what I'm
saying yeah but I'm so I'm just saying
that women are a lot more complicated in
that regard like you said like dudes
tend to be generally tend to be like
more visually oriented yeah but women
are are to some degree but not as much
like we can actually kind of
finagle all kind of different situations
says that she doesn't have the female
strategy she says her her and she's kind
of like got Asperger's and [__] she's
real like
you should listen to her you'd probably
[__] well the way you were describing
her I was like that kind of sounds like
me so I think he's a super analytical
and logical and yeah yeah yeah she's
very male I'm like the way that she
thinks she knows she's like that
I'm like that for her it's all visual I
told you my ex-husband used to call me
Spock yeah yeah you are spot yeah
like like disparagingly and I was like
okay but I'm taking that as a compliment
so yeah that's the way she is
she's like uh but to her it's visual
she uh
she says she's on friendly terms with
those customers if she doesn't like them
she doesn't do business with him she
won't have them back
but uh there there are there aren't
people she wants to live with or spend
any time with that but you know what I
mean yeah I get that they're not like
that it's a different generation and
there's nothing really in common
yeah I get that and you have to cater to
them
yeah and you know I'm not a big fan of
having to do that you're right yeah well
the thing about it too is that a lot of
I mean
what we're doing we're going to be
trading somewhat uh you know on people
who maybe see us as a little exotic yeah
because of the goth thing and in general
like those kind of people that are just
like like you know what I mean like
those kind of people like get on my
nerves yeah but I do kind of I don't
know I get it and you know we're we are
going to be kind of
taking advantage of that yeah but
there's other ways that you know me and
Jenny have discussed it you know we're
kind of natural Doms you know we're both
Doms
we're both [__] that's why that's
what he's saying yeah we're both
dominant personalities that's why well
that's why we kind of like butt heads a
lot of the time yeah because it's like
because you're trying to tell me what to
do I'm like [__] don't you tell
me what to do people don't understand I
mean they see me you know maybe I'll
look physically intimidating remember I
look boisterous and [__] and she gets
met you guys don't understand that
[__] she doesn't yield to me
I don't yield to her either we're both
very dominant we fight but not in the
way that other people would fight we
just there's a battle of wills sometimes
but it is yeah it's funny to me I I
don't take it because we are both very
very stubborn yeah neither one of us
likes being told what to do right
um so yeah so we both have a problem
like if somebody we don't like Authority
neither one of us likes no and so yeah
so it's just kind of like it's hard like
to get one of us to do something that
the other one because it's like well we
do this and I'm like no I don't want to
do that because I'm you know just
spiteful you know what I mean yeah it
does it works out well like I said I
mean we've been together what 12 years
almost 13 yeah at this point I think
it's well we've known each other for
longer than that yeah probably for close
to 14 years but we've been together
since
2011. and look man yeah all [__] that
have been married and everything you're
lightweights compared to us because me
and Jenny lived with each other
24 7 within Arms Reach for probably
eight years yeah we were just constantly
on top of it like eight years all the
time we were like within arms reaching
each other eight or nine years
and we didn't drive each other crazy
with just some weird [__] yeah and the
weird thing about it the first time do
you know a couple years that well it was
probably like how long ago was it when
you went to see your dad
um with the whole turkey neck situation
that was the first time and you ended up
being gone for two weeks yeah that was
the first time in a decade yeah that we
had been apart yeah it was like I was
missing a twin it was so weird yeah and
Pookie didn't recognize me when I came
back she's like
yeah because he was gone well I thought
he was only a few seconds because the
thing about like when he went yeah um it
basically happened like in a day like
his dad called and he's like um he that
he needed um you know heart bypass and
stuff and Tom's like [__] I gotta fly
out there so he flew out there like
literally I think it was the same day or
the next day like we found you a flight
and he thought he was he's like I don't
know how long I'm gonna be here you know
he's gonna go through the surgery we're
gonna see how it comes out of it and
it's like so I was just like okay
whatever take whatever time you need and
then so he was planning a week at first
but then like you know his dad was still
in recovery so he ended up staying like
another week because it was too
expensive for him to fly back and all
this other stuff so that two weeks like
I said it was so weird because that was
the first time for the decade prior to
that we had been together pretty much
all the time all the time yeah you know
what I mean so it was just very very
weird like you not being there suddenly
it was like super super bizarre it was
weird it was very weird oh yeah
because I hadn't realized how long we
had been together
and I mean really together
and I said we've been together for a
unit yeah but you work full-time jobs
apart from each other Jenny was working
from the home
well for the for the last from 2016.
yeah like prior to that I went to a
right job like a regular person but and
and I'm I'm basically living off a
[__] military retirement Right
medical retirement so I can stay home
and just make money yeah
um it's not enough to pay all these
[__] bills though well yeah it used
to be but not now you know so uh
we were together all the [__] time
and we had a lot of disposable time so
we're doing stuff in the clubs and
[__] doing gangster business with
[__] clubs and [__]
Gangsta business and all kinds of words
this is only a matter of time before we
were we're natural entertainers though
you know grafters and grandpars knows me
and grandpas went to [__] driving
school together man we had a good did
shows and [__] I like you know I like
I couldn't be a professional actor like
in the old school ways
you know they'd kind of Casting Couch my
ass I wanted to be a real person I don't
you know I wanted to go out and do real
[__] I didn't want to be a professional
Pretender
you know
probably would have been better off as a
comic
yeah I think you missed your calling on
that one I used to tell you like a long
time ago I was like yeah you probably
should have been a stand-up should have
been a cop I think you'd have been
really good at that well I'm already
kind of a comic now I don't have to
[__] go anywhere now I got on YouTube
and a lot of my heroes were comics
you know Eddie Murphy
Buddy Hackett you know those guys
[__] Richard Pryor George Carlin
George Carlin
if I can
they're just I think Comics were more
important than actors they just because
they could give their personal [__]
Flair you knew what they were thinking
[__] Dave Chappelle Dave Chappelle's
a [__] Master right well and a lot of
times the great thing about comedians is
that they can actually kind of
say uh uncomfortable truths but because
it's filtered through humor yeah it's
the Court Jester sure Court Jester so
and I think that's a really good card
like I I think people kind of like
disparage comedians maybe like as being
like frivolous or not that important but
I actually think they're very important
that's right John Dangerfield was good
too oh yeah riding danger he was good
I used to honestly I hadn't I haven't
seen a lot of the newer ones but during
the 90s I was all about [__] I used
to watch Comedy Central all the [__]
time yeah thank you Ian England what's
up it's Friday baby yes it is yeah like
I said this seemed like the longest
[__] week ever I guess because at
work like the other designer guy was
like on vacation this week so I had to
do everything another game was Steve
Martin his silly ass
John Belushi was a pretty good man I
even like Steve Martin like in his
movies like a jerk [__] although I'm I
will I will go to my grave saying my
favorite Steve Martin movie is the Man
with Two Brains yeah oh my [__] God I
love it like the most the sadist man
from [__] little shopping oh yeah
yeah like he was only in that for like
five minutes but holy [__] he stole that
[__] thing
who's the sadist biker the dead [__]
dentist
we're not scared of stream mates because
we come from clubs where there's a big
fetish element going on
and [__] we know people in the
[__] BDSM community and that whole
[__] lifestyle
they have their own thing going on but
goth and Industrial and [__] fetish
was [__] right there that happened in
the same clubs
so um
the whole thing that God got us on this
idea was Jed saying yeah I could be a
dominatrix who said this [__] on the
show we started thinking about it yeah I
was like oh my God if someone would pay
me to step on their nuts I'm all about
it
I can handle security I'll take you
there but then the more I was thinking
about I was like yeah it's
actually going there it's better to just
do that [__] online yeah it's like then
you don't actually have to touch anybody
you don't have to go anywhere gross yeah
we just get [__] on a stream mate well
they got some [__] badass dominatrix
on stream mates and they're not doing
anything sexual they're just talking
dirty and [__] telling dudes this
shut the [__] up they had a Romanian one
that's
what was his name bastet what's her name
and she had a whole [__] Throne set
up
she had a real it was the room was black
she was in Romania she had the [__]
thick Romanian accent sound like Bella
Lugosi talking to a female Bella Lugosi
she started chastising some dude for
being wrong and he started sending her
money and she [__] took out a big old
dildo and threw the [__] on the ground
and then filming it
that [__] big old dildo sitting this
big old black dildo sitting on the
ground and then she starts squirting oil
on it and ticks her shoot takes her feet
out of her shoes she had pretty little
feet and she's rubbing and rubbing
rubbing it with his feet and the dude he
was spinning ding ding ding he would
have sent her 30 dollars
see it's like two at all four minutes
that's right and then she told him to
leave
yeah get the [__] out of here yeah you
leave you come back later
you come back later yeah
yeah that was I was like good job see
like I said with that [__] I like that
I'll handle that [__] like I
said so
but I don't you know I don't know I just
because I think that to me that would
seem like
yeah I could be mean and stuff like that
but that would seem too much like I like
this kind of situation where we're just
kind of like hanging out and just being
our regular selves yeah so I kind of
think that is probably the way to go
because if I have to go too much into
acting or a Persona or anything like
that it starts to become like less the
pegging Community I don't even know if
that's a specific it's not a community I
mean I feel like well I guess it's a
community in the sense that there's a
set amount of people that do it but it's
just like I don't know I feel like
that's probably the stuff I ain't
mentioning nothing man but there's these
girls I know man who come up [__] and
say oh yeah yeah I used to Peg to him
all the time and this and that and
[__] these dudes man are getting
pegged by these [__] women
it's a lot more common than I thought it
was yeah it's very common I was just
going like dude it's very common
Tom's very uncomfortable yeah I'm
getting very comfortable two things
bother me man [__] pegging and
sounding
yeah I don't know I don't I'd rather get
sounded than Peg but really probably
yeah well yeah I guess I could because
if I was [__] a real real aroused you
know what I mean
it's [__] rock hard and everything's
lubed up you start sticking something
down it might feel good I got this weird
idea that it might feel good
I mean it's not not it's not so [__]
wrong not a ton of people are into it
but there are like a not insubstantial
chunk of people that are into it it
looks like it itches
I can't imagine what it would it looks
like man but it made me very
uncomfortable
I mean I sold a few sounding kids when I
was selling this but I mean that was I
only probably sold one we all want to
see some wild [__] go to your browser
and go look at Penelope Black Diamond
sounding
all right well she sounds her boyfriend
and she's this German porn star girl she
only works with her husband huge
beach ball size implants and huge
pierced
labia they're [__] the piercings are
the size of bracelets going through her
and she's pretty
just she is she is actually yeah real
and she's into like real long
fingernails and toenails that curl over
the [__] ends of her [__]
I think they're all false I think
they're fake toenails I don't know how
many gonna live with toenails that long
but they curl yeah you can't wear shoes
well you'd have to wear a flip like four
inch long thank you murder Hornet what
do you say Friday keeping the flash
bulbs keep them flash bulbs coming
people
we're gonna drink all that [__] up
tonight at the club probably I want
another drink man but I can't drink can
I have another one I gotta drive can I
have another yeah I don't have to drive
okay I do have to put uh fake lashes on
though all right so that should be super
fun after I've had a couple drinks not
yet
here's the thing
did you get blue ones and blue ones and
green ones and I got records of the bank
paying them but when I go to that site
there's no record of me buying them
uh-oh because I didn't I didn't I didn't
make a an account and a cow are you just
like a guest right so I don't know
I may do it again
Tammy says Spock just moved
um it might be because sometimes Pokey
goes back there and like rubs on the
side of Spock's leg and if you can't see
her then it looks like Spock is going
like that like by himself like Pookie
for some reason like really really loves
like to rub on Spock's leg back there so
I don't I don't know maybe it was her
uh John Gore said Elvira was kind of a
Dom yeah she was how she was always kind
of glaring at the viewers like what are
you looking at creep yeah and she was
always kind of like insulting people and
stuff like that see I like that kind of
thing because that was kind of like a
soft Dom I kind of feel like she was
just uh you know not being like mean
mean but just kind of like low-key mean
um and Victor's talking about catheters
talking about putting in catheters yeah
it's like I don't
I don't know like it depends on because
the sounded kids it's you know it's much
like a kit where you would get like you
know just butt plugs or something like
that where it's just like it starts out
small one and then you know they get
bigger and bigger
so I don't imagine because some of the
like smaller ones the set in the
sounding kit are like pretty thin so I
don't imagine it would be that bad and
like Victor pointed out that he put in
catheters all the time so
you know
I don't imagine it's super comfortable
but I can't imagine it being like super
super painful I don't know it's not real
common like I said but we did like see
some videos of it and Tom was just like
squirming the whole time
which of course maybe maybe laugh even
harder like any time we see any porn
that like makes Tom really uncomfortable
I just like make him keep watching it
because it's like very very funny to me
because I'm an [__] but you know I
mean like I said well we found that one
with like the woman in the super high
heels like with the guy like putting his
nuts through the is it like a purpose
made box
had like a hole in the top and he like
stuck his nuts up flicked through the
hole and then she was like stabbing man
she was really going to town she she was
like squishing I'm like oh my God are
they gonna like burst like grapes holy
[__] let's find out so I just like I
want I wanted to see what would happen
um so I was watching that and so I'm
just like like the whole time and it's
that just like made me laugh even harder
because I'm kind of a dick but uh yeah
Zach said I Googled that chick once and
her tits gave me nightmares the skin
around the implants is all stretched out
okay
yeah that'll happen
Tammy said oh okay maybe it was Pookie
yeah she does uh she does that a lot she
kind of goes back there and rubs on him
because I've seen it happen a couple
times just in the background like he'll
be like Spock will be going like that
because uh you know
Zach says some of the best uh prawn I've
we found lately yeah Katie Brown uh we
found lately is from Finnish dudes
they're into some strange [__] but I'm
into it let me just steal a little bit
of that okay
uh Victor said are we still starting a
GoFundMe to give Tom five thousand
dollars to Jenny can pick that some [__]
see well you said that you were gonna
tell anybody the amount but then you did
anyway yeah the thing is is look that's
five grand I'm talking about five grand
for me it's gonna that's gonna come
through what's called gold they take 65
percent
okay so you're saying you're talking
more like 10 grand
okay so you're up in the Annie what it
would be 10 grand and five of it we
would get
like I said Jenny could be doing that
[__] for free I ain't letting you have
none of that
you would even give me Eddie
not zero harsh zero I mean I only way I
can salvage my manhood
I made that [__] Peg man I took all the
money took all the money
I suck don't believe that's what's gonna
happen
yeah somebody would really have to have
like a really lot of disposable income
and really really wanna want to see you
uncomfortable
me really really happy
she's trying to make it she's a money
maker she's a money maker I know damn
you can't better stop talking about it
because like I said people are gonna
[__] pull their wreaths more it's
just gonna start fueling
It's Gonna Get Around
it's gonna get around all the Internet
it's like hey if we read like this
amount of money who chooses the dick see
and then they're gonna oh and then
they're gonna wanna like fight now hey
if I give you a thousand dollars like
let me come in like choose the strap on
yeah and then they're gonna start
talking about that [__] uh Bad Dragon
Rhino
that's the size of a [__] coffee can
you say yeah they're gonna talk about it
oh yeah I haven't seen that one I've
seen some of the other like I've seen
some of the other Bad Dragon ones but um
yeah I haven't seen I haven't seen the
bad Rhino one yeah there's a [__] one
it's like a rhino it's like three feet
long and about a big round as a coffee
can
they couldn't do it it's just a gimmick
I don't think anybody could do that
that's what I mean it's like some well I
don't know I've seen this before here's
some chicks like it might be dead anal
yeah girl from Argentina they could
probably do that I would call a girl
she's a woman
I just not too long ago
um I read a novella which was called
womb and the whole premise of that
spoiler alert if you haven't read it
um was this dude that was looking for a
woman who
let's put it this way was big enough to
fit his entire head inside
because he wanted to crawl back into the
womb now all the gays are saying how
much GoFundMe takes and then I
trying to [__]
[Laughter]
ing I know all my gay fans
but there's not enough for y'all see I'm
secure I'm secure my virginity is secure
we'll see it is
I'm just rubbing my hands together
[Laughter]
I told you I'm a little bit sadistic
almost I love you Tom but it's just you
know what I mean but it is very funny
man I am kind of mean well it's it's
just very I find it very funny
um to make you uncomfortable
yeah that's just very funny to me like I
said the the few times we watch porn
that we're like you know that we've came
across like some sounding [__] or like
the woman stepping on the dudes nuts and
all that kind of stuff like I just wanna
yeah he was just like [__] a [__]
wall squirming around and I was just
like no leave it on that's it's
hilarious it's hilarious I'm just like
laugh and laugh
uh
[__] catheters
he has to pick out and buy the dildo
yeah I mean
this I I don't know like I said I'm I'm
looking forward to this situation but
we'll we'll see we'll see what happens
she told me I've streamed me yeah I'm
not talking about the pegging although
you guys started on this [__] man this
hits me though well I mean you to be
fair you to kind of bring it up before
because that was
something that we were talking we've
talked about this even before we talked
about it on the show because that was
one of the things you brought up like
what if somebody says I mean the thing
about it though is that when you're on
stream mate you don't have to do
anything that people say no like you can
have they have a thing where it's like
you know tips but you have a tip menu is
what you have and it's just like you
know you can send it back too yeah you
can stand back yeah where it's just kind
of like five gold for this or 10 or
whatever but like you can pick whatever
you want to put on there so it's like if
there's nothing if there's something you
don't want to do you don't have to put
it on your tip menu they got shows and
if somebody asks you to do it you can go
hey I don't do that they got they got
shows on stream mates or a couple shows
with a couple drinking basically doing
drinking games and flashing titties and
just doing stupid [__] for the drinking
game and everybody in yeah it's just
like do a shop or yeah and the customers
are drunk and the [__] people on
doing the streamers see that sounds fun
so you never can't tell what what's
going on over there
I mean we'll have to look I'm not really
sure because I think that streammate you
can't just wing it and put like whatever
you want on your tip menu I think
there's like a there's a preset there's
a preset list of things you can pick
from oh there's a lot of it's fetish
oriented too right like uh one we gotta
have on there is [__] dick judgment
oh is that one of the one of the one of
the things you could do which what does
that is to have this [__] micro
phallus [__] that have this
sucking uh this innate desire to show it
to everybody and to have them rate it
and humiliate it
okay all right I can do that yeah so
they
for a certain amount of money they are
allowed through streammate to send you a
photo of their [__] junk and then
you're you can rate it
and talk about it
to them and they get off on it talk
about how we're gonna need the tweezers
yeah yeah so you know and evidently the
ones that really do it a lot are dudes
that [__] are tiny
and they want to be humiliated
interesting yeah
okay so we definitely we don't know if
that and you would be no way of knowing
if that was actually theirs too I mean
yeah they might just be sending a random
picture you know
so you can just pull one off the
internet yeah [__] might be well
hung and jerking it to you telling them
how small he is Timmy said we can
humiliate man yeah I can I can do that
no problem I can too
yeah
it's so easy yeah
I can add a flare that only a man can
add it's easy but uh but yeah so yeah we
definitely have to have dick judgment
I'm not really sure like I said I don't
know what all of the CH what all of the
options are
like I've seen some of like I know that
there's some that aren't even sexual
that are just like take a shot yeah like
if you're drinking yeah so we'll
definitely have to have that right
lick your own nipple uh I can't quite
reach my own yeah you did pretty good I
mean yeah
um I kind of can there's there's uh
especially if you're upside down
but uh well that yeah now that you put
it that way yeah because yeah if I was
upside down yeah I would flop right yeah
yeah yeah yeah that might help
think of that
now I've heard doing the research uh the
male performers were pissed because the
the selection is mostly female or it's
mostly ordered towards female audiences
but that's because most of the
I mean the bulk of the audience is
straight men yeah I mean there's a large
contingent of gay men on there too but
um yeah but they didn't they didn't
change
the options right options for the for
the male performance
it's a lot of male performers on there
serving the male community
yeah I was actually I was watching I
can't remember what his name was but um
he makes a lot of videos about I think
he does ChatterBait actually and maybe
streamate as well but he was talking
about it too
um
he works a lot like he works like but he
makes a lot of money at it a lot of them
are straight
this guy this guy wasn't yeah a lot of
straight guys doing it yeah
it helps if you're [__] jacked uh the
top ones were
from what I saw
Tammy said what I can't see Tom lick his
own nipple I mean probably I could you
don't think you could ah no
no probably not you probably can't reach
it
the uh
what was that saying uh before some
crazy [__] like that
another thing is that when you go on
stream mate the best thing to do is just
block Colombia
because Colombia is [__] jam-packed
full of [__] people poor people and
pretty girls [__]
grow on trees in Colombia
and so when you go in there there's
going to be 40 or 50 of them from
Columbia sitting there and they don't
speak any English
and they just kind of jam up the
airwaves and they don't really seem to
be getting a lot of action either most
of them just sitting there waiting
so see and I kind of feel like that's
where we have a leg up on a lot of the
stuff because the the streams that I've
seen on there a lot of the people are on
for a long time but most of the time
they're just kind of like hanging out
because of I mean the bulk of them are
solo females yeah so they're just going
to be like laying there on their bed or
whatever you just fall asleep right and
just like wait or they're on their phone
or whatever and it's like I just kind of
envisioned like look if we can't be just
like entertaining and talking and stuff
like that then we should just get off
and come back on like later most of the
most girls are not cut out for that work
they're on their phone
they they can't socialize enough they
don't know how to talk they don't know
how to talk to guys there's no
personality no streets
no screen charm
so they're not in the game for very long
they're not entertainers
well like I said I think you've got to
be entertaining being pretty isn't
enough and I think it'd be easier for us
too because like I said if there's
nobody in the room or nobody in the room
is talking we can at least talk to each
other and you know us talking will spur
them into talking so it's like it's not
just me hanging out having to like
entertain people like you know we can
talk to each other and I think that
would be helpful going through the
ardumer research they had a 68 year old
female British bodybuilder
uh I wouldn't say she was she probably
ifbb quality but not more like uh bikini
model
and she was working it she was 68 she
looked [__] great
all right and she was working the crowd
she was getting a lot of attention
because she was playing the old card I'm
an old lady
look at me and dudes were all over it
and she going private come back going
private she was on there for a couple
hours every time I go to chat I go check
back and see if Steve was still
streaming and she was still getting guys
going
so really it's not
just for it's not really for young
people per se it's just anybody who can
attract attention
and she was British she had a real nice
accent she was funny
and she was just real Charming
and she could just
get these little going private acts
jerking them dudes off
so she probably made several hundred
dollars in a few hours there
just doing that yeah probably didn't
take her clothes off
like I said I mean obviously like being
young and pretty helps but it almost it
can almost cause you to [__]
um get lost in the Woodwork though
because yeah because there's a lot of
them there's a lot of those they were
going for that woman because she was 68
she looked great well she stood out she
stood out she had something distinct
right right that's what I mean because
because there's so many people on there
and like I said you know
young pretty girls on there are a dime a
dozen yeah she's in Colombia you really
really have to do something to like
differentiate yourself that's what I say
just go ahead and block Columbia there's
just gonna be these young pretty girls
just sitting there doing nothing
you can't talk to them they don't speak
English
Yeah man they just
if you're a Spanish speaker you might
have fun with them but they're just
sitting there looking through phones and
they're not entertaining they're just
like waiting for somebody to yeah their
looks isn't enough yeah people want
entertainment
well yeah I kind of feel like that's why
a lot especially you know stream mate
which like I said seems to attract like
a slightly higher uh Echelon I guess or
people with slightly more money
um do you have to have a credit card to
get on there yes I mean they're on there
to spend some money and like spend some
time they don't just want to see
somebody you know jerk themselves off or
you know and jerk themselves off but I
they want somebody like to interact with
and somebody that's gonna be like
interacting with them you know what I
mean so
I kind of feel like you know we will
probably do well in that regard success
is possible for men to locate you
lactate lactate is that we said okay I
said locator no lactate uh yeah they can
uh dudes taking steroids can lactate
I've never lacked I've heard that yeah
um well because all the same I mean men
are built on a women's I mean all uh
fetuses are female to start with and
then they modify into them and then they
modify into a male so we have all the
same [__] it's just you know
but the uh
um a dude he said can men lactate yeah
but not under normal circumstances you
have to be uh [__] I have a lot of
[__] up hormones
a lot of progesterone and a lot of a lot
of um
uh estrogen in your system
but probably mostly progesterone might
probably do it
and you could have high progesterone
levels if you were taking lots of
nadralone which is a synthetic copy of
testosterone
there's things I can the body reacts to
whatever you inject into it
it tries to counteract it to make a
balance so if you start dumping a lot of
[__] testosterone like
hormones or synthetic copies of things
like testosterone known as steroids if
you start doing that putting those into
your body the body might react in a
weird ways to try to balance that out
try to it'll try to [__] dump a bunch
of [__] progesterone and a bunch of
estrogen into your system
which can lead to gynecomastia which
means [__] tits you know [__] men
with tits that happens The Rock had that
a little bit but he got it corrected cut
it you can cut it out there are ways to
chemically kind of stop that from
happening too through hormone blockers
estrogen blockers
but I've heard of guys lactating
I've been under very very heavy heavy
Cycles
of [__] uh I think it was natural on
ninja lone deca
which is a one of the Esters of
nadralone it's real common when you can
put on a lot of muscle real quickly it's
like super Super Hyper testosterone
but without the side effects of
testosterone so it has a much higher
overdose point you can take a lot of
that a lot more of that than you could
test
I think that I think was Deca that did
that
um
but no dudes are lactating
they didn't
grow
tits though
just weird
the body is a weird thing
that's all kind of crazy yeah yeah
it is kind of weird when you think about
it yeah
I was thinking the other day that
I don't know why I had this weird
thought when I was like driving to work
the other day but I was thinking that
wouldn't it be weird if like all of your
internal organs like became
independently sentient and started like
conspiring against you
I feel like that sometimes that some of
my organs are doing that
because it's almost nine o'clock huh it
is yeah but Zach said um talking about
male lactation said you know there's
someone out there who's into that I mean
I know for sure yeah I mean there's
someone that out there that's into
everything to be honest whatever you can
think of but there is like a whole
subset of like women's like lactation
porn which like I said I wasn't really I
never thought of it as being something
that would be like
interesting but like we came across some
one day and I was like that's kind of
hot like yeah I never really that never
really occurred to me that it would be
but I was just kind of like well that
particular one was like yeah you talking
about the one with a Japanese girl yeah
yeah that one yeah yeah there's one
that's particularly good man she could
uh spray it's a Japanese girl sitting on
a chair on a black background and just
some dude with who's shirtless you never
see his face goes in there and just
starts milking her and she [__]
sprays out huge [__] Showers of the
[__] it was something else
and he
he um starts slowly working on her one
and then the other it builds up to it
and she's definitely getting off on it
definitely it looked like it felt good
because he's good he's doing besides
he's doing his Japanese shiatsu
he learned that [__] directly from you
know I was going to say
yeah breast milk extraction
expression he's expressing the milk yes
yeah yeah
yeah
just for the record yeah I just thought
I'd put that out there but uh I do
research [__] like Japanese lactation
that's probably the top one I I don't
remember I mean it's been a long time
since we've seen it that's a classic
That's a classic one it is a classic
yeah yeah I really liked that one
actually
because I was like wow look at her spray
yeah
be like she's like a [__] fire six or
seven Jets of it out of each [__]
aerial [__] experience wow and it was
like that's amazing yeah far too like
five feet yeah she got some distance
yeah it was crazy and he's doing like
that and it's just like bulging and she
and he's spraying it in her own face and
everything that was it was it was pretty
cool
it was pretty cool it was pretty cool
yeah
because I was like I don't know it's
just I know we're using that Oriental
style
and everything like that but it's just
like I don't know I've just always
thought I was like ooh like you can make
milk with your tits that's like super
weird yeah like it's not weird but it's
I don't know it seems kind of weird
[Laughter]
you know what I mean murder Hornet said
uh I need to refill my test okay
yeah
uh Victor says all men are trans
probably I mean
well I mean we're not as far apart as
it's not really uh yeah well there's a
lot of differences yeah but there's a
lot of similarities as well with the
same species
well done and that goes well I'm not
speaking for everyone yeah
I've met a few people that I think were
probably not the same species but you
know the male female division
pre-human it goes way back into [__]
single cell organisms doing the [__]
through what they call it uh sexual
sexual reproduction
started in a single-celled organisms and
there was sexual differentiation between
them
just
you really see the difference it started
in things like fish
and reptiles you see a difference
although some reptiles can change sex
yeah yeah same amphibians can't yeah
and some fish can yeah I think it's not
the ones they could probably only do it
once uh no it's not it's actually not
that uncommon but can they do it back
and forth uh some species can yeah okay
all right just whatever is uh necessary
at the time
Zach says I'm definitely not the same
species I feel like that sometimes too
I I feel yeah I get where you're coming
from I I kind of feel like I'm not from
this planet so
I don't know I feel like maybe a lot of
people feel like do you ever feel like
that what's that that you're not from
this planet I don't worry about it I'm
so I'm so myopic I'm so worried about
myself that I don't care if I belong
here or not
I'm so self-absorbed give a [__] if I
fit or not just yeah well at least at
least you realize how self-absorbed you
are yeah that's something yeah that's
step one to getting better but um
no I just I don't know
maybe I did maybe it's just that I hope
that I'm from another planet so I can go
back there someday
all right look uh let's go ahead and end
the show Joe we're starting to get ready
because we gotta leave in a bit Yeah
because we uh yeah we're actually gonna
go to Memento
you gotta put your eyelashes on all I
have to do is put my shoes on put my
eyelashes on and you gotta tighten the
course and then it'll be well probably I
should go to the bathroom because yeah
me too and then we'll get out of here
let's see we'll see how fun we'll see
how funny it is me trying to put fake
lashes on all right with I'm not drunk
drunk but I'm a little bit tipsy she's
looking so [__] hot if I wish I could
get a [__] film of this man [__] a
man
I'm trying to hit man
we can make money right now
well I told you like we started you were
texting me at work I got this [__] on
video man I'm going [__] crazy on
this [__] man and I look huge in the
[__] I look back and I was like man
this looks like bestiality it's like
it's like you in a bowl
how the [__] does it have I don't know
just the sexual dimorphism
yeah I'm starting to become a baboon I
look like a [__] baboon man
yeah it does look like yeah
it's not that bad you're not all furry
yeah right yeah but yeah the way you're
going at it sure yeah
I'll show it to you again tomorrow
because like I said we need to sit down
because I want you to help me edit it
all right because you know you're in the
[__] too so I want you to all right you
know I want you to collaborate with me
on it you know what I mean you only have
to be about 15 minutes long I mean the
stuff that's just me I don't really care
but you know what I mean I haven't seen
that yet
yeah I'll show you I'll show you some of
that that I made all right look let's
shut it down Jim okay we're gonna shut
it down
um and then on Sunday we will be back
talking about it'll either be bad
lieutenant or the professional because
xanadas sent us both of those so we're
gonna watch one of those probably
tomorrow night and we'll talk about that
on Sunday so hopefully you guys have a
good rest of your Friday night have a
good day tomorrow and we will see you
guys again on Sunday evening
good night